well with me now it's the boss of one of
the big six energy companies Scottish
powers chief corporate officer Keith
Anderson so Keith good evening to you
how much is this going to cost you well
I think the first thing we need to look
at here is that you know the the thing
we're trying to do and the biggest focus
for us is what's the best thing for the
customer and how do we do that from our
perspective the best thing is to get
more customers engaged in the market
we've been working very hard to do that
we've already got more than 60% of our
customers on good valued products away
from the old-style
SVT and that's a very leading position
for the industry I think that
disappointing thing I feel today is that
actually the potential here in the risk
of a place cap is that it takes 13
million people field not on those good
products and it actually discourages of
them from taking part in the market
around yeah and what we want to do is we
want to encourage those people to come
into the market and we think the best
thing to do would be to scrap the
old-style stand available tariffs take
those 30 million people and put them
into the market and if we've already got
40 energy companies competing in that
market of 8 to 10 million people think
about how much better the market would
be with another 30 million people in the
market so you're gonna take a lead on
this you gonna voloshyn stand a variable
terrace yourself so we've been we've
been saying that our view was that the
whole market should get rid of a SVT's
and that's why we've pushed so far and
so hard to get 60 percent of our
customers away from that the good thing
is off gem two days ago announced some
changes to the rules which makes it no
easier to do that so now when a customer
comes to the end of a product at the end
of a year they don't need to be put back
on to stand available tariff we can now
put them on to a better product that
will drive this even faster and that's
better again and again the concern I
have is that the message the place cap
cents to 13 million people is don't do
anything stay where you are
because we're going to come and fix it
for you and our view is no don't
says I'm going to only stage engage with
us now come and speak to us now and
we'll fix this for you now we'll put you
on a better product now and you'll get a
better deal note well why is it you
think in the in the face of all that and
competition and Markets Authority have
explicitly urged the government not to
do this why do you think they are I'm
not too sure aim you don't because
there's a say overview and we would
agree with the competition and Markets
Authority actually capping discourages
competition and it discourages markets
and that's what will offer the best
solution engagement is the best thing
engagement is what drives loyalty
because customers feel that being
engaged they're being listened to and
that's the best place for us to be we've
got 60 percent of our customers actively
engaged with us as a company and we want
to keep pushing that all the way the 100
percent in fairness so I mean this isn't
going to come in till 2020 it may not
last for very long it certainly won't
come in would last till 2020 won't come
in till next year sometime
shares in centrica and Scottish and
Southern were two of the biggest gamers
on the foot see today the industry's
been led off hasn't it well I how long
it takes the legislation to go through
the House of Commons and go through the
process I'm not too sure how quickly
that'll happen but our view is the
faster the industry moves to switching
people away from a SVT and say we've
shown it can be done we're a leading
position in the industry are called to
others and the industry has follow our
lead push this drivers get people away
from SVT get people engaged in the
market that shows people let me get the
best product on the market it will show
the government that people are engaging
in the market and we don't need place
caps you've shown great clark miss
presumably yes absolutely and what did
he say well I think his position is he's
sitting saying you know he doesn't
believe that the markets working he
doesn't he keeps talking about a lack of
loyalty and and companies not being
loyal over views it's not about loyalty
this is about engagement engagement is
what drives loyalty we've got 60 percent
of our customers who are incredibly
loyal to us they're also incredibly
engaged in the market and that's the
brief competition should work that's the
way markets work and that's the way
people get the best deal all right Keith
Anderson from Scottish power we've got
to leave you there appreciate you
joining me